good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast it is tuesday
the first tuesday in november it is
election day it is a beautiful se
literally for the first time in like 11
days it is sunny look at me if you're
watching me on youtube you've got
sun on your arm i'm literally getting
tan as i sit here is that amazing you
guys
it's a beautiful day in new york city it
is a beautiful day to
vote everyone make sure you get out the
vote today it's election day
very exciting it's also important to let
freedom ring it is it is this is
important
let the whole world sing
i don't know how it goes after that
[Music]
this is terrible tina mcbride is rolling
up
she is you know what honestly like mark
tina mcbride is
one of my favorite country singers not
even country just like all around genre
she's such a talent she's glad you
brought that up yeah no she really is
but that was a disgrace
to her name martina mcbride um we have a
great show for you guys today of course
the fast five stories
jackie and i also both watched i can
never remember the name the american
crime
that's what i'm saying it's american
murder the family family next door
which not a good name for it too long
and also like
they're just not a good name it really
just should have been called like
justice for shanann
and her girls yeah justice for shannon
and the girls um we're gonna do that in
our tv recap
really glad that you recommended it to
me even though i had the
biggest pit in my stomach the whole time
because like you know how it ends but
it's just like i don't know how we get
there
and it was just it's just a [ __ ]
terrible story
and it really like ruined my day so
thank you happy to ruin your day
always we'll recap it and i'll share all
of my thoughts
at the end last night we recorded the
redheads finally
this episode is actually really funny
because there was like a few times in
the past two weeks we were supposed to
record and for one reason or another
we got derailed because you know i said
last week we would be recording and then
that didn't wind up happening
so everyone was just sort of on one and
just the camaraderie within the webheads
in this episode is just so
hysterical the book again you know we
have a wide
array of opinions so whether you loved
the book or hated the book we have
your opinion somewhere in that how did
the book score on the redheads very
tough chart
i don't want to spoil it okay it was not
our highest rated book by any means was
it your lowest
i don't think so but we actually so in
our next episode for december we're
going to do a year-end
roundup where we sort of like re-rate
the books based on
the other books we read because we
always like rate each book like sort of
in a
whole and we don't compare it to like
what about the one before i feel like
the ratings don't always represent like
how good this book is compared to the
last one we read or the next one
well i have a feeling your january 2021
book will probably be the highest rated
of 2021.
yeah i that's what the rumor mill is
sort of swirling on about
yeah because that's because it's my book
girls no job check it out
so the new episode of the redhead shops
on thursday so that was really fun to
record get all the girls together
the girls plus magnolia who met bruno
last night
i was really nervous for this meeting of
the minds because magnolia is
she's a fighter she's a diva she she
will go hard she will rip your head off
and bruno's a lover and they got
together and it was
beautiful it was magic i'm so happy to
hear that bruno shared his
bully sticks with her oh it was really
really cute now we got to get theo in
the mix
we gotta get the own mix but i'm
literally scared to see theo and bruno
because
magnolia as far as i thought was like
the smallest dog of all time but
seeing her next to bruno she's massive
no puppies are so small and it's like
they grow right in front of you so you
don't realize like
magnolia is massive i don't know if
you've seen her recently she's a horse
no i haven't seen her but i believe it
she actually is extremely horse-like
you know what i do agree i doth agree
like her
coat is extremely shiny and horsy she
has a horse's thigh when she lays down
it's like a horse in a barn with that
muscular thigh
very horsy it's like that sea biscuit
like chess her name should really be
secretariat
yeah she's got that nice red coat that's
also a content upper
secretary oh yes such
and the grandma from hannah montana
yes that's by the way that actress an
icon
she's like whenever they can't get kathy
bates they get this woman i don't know
her name
is good she's so good also that reminded
me she should find out her name because
justice is here
to disrespect her like that also there
needs to be an award show that gives out
like icon awards for like
no name underrated character i couldn't
agree more ever
alicia maywitt alicia witt whatever
alicia may also um victor garber
he deserves every award but i think he
actually has oscars and he is like real
his name carries weight so i don't think
he would um qualify for our award show
okay i got her name what is it it's like
it won't ring any sort of no of course
not it's the cutest name and it's
so hurt was it like susie bell or
something cuter go
margo martindale oh margo
um also what i watched last night which
was truly a content upper
was jeopardy and it was the
the first round was romantic comedy
themed
so like the categories for rom-coms
failure to lunch
27 dresses love actually failures
yeah the category was about food but it
was like a rom-com theme oh
love actually was an answer did you feel
prepared no because you haven't watched
it do you still feel so proud of that
choice
no even though i'm just like so young
you're so young
so naive no i know and it didn't you
know maybe
last night i grew up a little bit
because i realized like maybe it's not
so cool to be the girl who's never seen
love actually no
i don't know if you can be the girl
who's never seen love actually and also
be the girl watching jeopardy all night
i think they they conflict
no you know what i actually am going to
stand my ground here i feel like i
operate in a very unique space in our
culture where i'm like a six year old
and a 60 year old like i'm very immature
but i'm also wise beyond my ears yeah
that's sort of like my style is what i'm
told yeah like i'm dressed like a
toddler and like a grandmother and you
know what get you a girl who could do
both
i've got my toddler clips in today so
festive for election day yeah you're
being
yeah you're todd the clips are like a
little super childish yeah i know and i
know i wore them yesterday and i usually
wouldn't do two days in a row but i just
just thought it was a nice way to pick
up on the colors in my sticker
wow such a faux pas clips the same two
days in a row
i wouldn't know no it's just like i
don't want to be like the girl who's
going to bring the girls who obviously
just went to wait and read to my clips
is anyone when you i don't know if you
ever use clips like these yes
every time you call those um i mean
they're keepa clips
yeah when we that's what i was gonna say
but i don't know what they're actually
calling me neither but when we were
in like um middle school in high school
all the boys because we went to jewish
school
all the boys had to wear yamakas which
are like those little skull caps skull
caps
and um they would when you were younger
and like they would always fall off you
would secure them in with those types of
clips so
they just in silver not in red no in
black no silver
oh i saw silver one black um they would
be referred to as kippah clips like if a
boy needed one the teacher was like you
need to keep up clip
and that's just what i call them now and
i don't know what like the industry name
for them actually is because i don't
think it's kpop clip
i don't know either but whenever i snap
them in i feel like that scene in
clueless when she's like sitting on the
chair like
snap it it took me a while to identify
how i was feeling it was sort of a
feeling of deja vu but i knew it wasn't
like
my own feeling it was a movie i had
watched and then i saw clueless recently
i was like that's it when she's sitting
on the couch watching
tv with josh and she's like putting all
these clips over here i just
every time my clip snaps in i'm just
like harked back to that yes yes yes yes
yes i wouldn't have automatically
associated it with that but now i do
i'm still stuck in the keypad clip time
of my life yeah no i graduated from
there
and now i'm just in like the 90s [ __ ]
vibe so i got about 16 right in jeopardy
which is not my best my best is 21
and i thought maybe i would do it in the
rom-com category but i did not so
i'm sorry to hear that there's that big
disappointment yeah but you know what
the great thing about jeopardy there's
always tomorrow
that's beautiful today claudia that's
beautiful yeah and i really encourage
you all to
start including jeopardy in your daily
lives it's really been
just a gift and alex trebek i always say
his last name is quebec
and because he is from canada alex
trebek is really just like this
guiding light and this force in our
culture and i think
it's like he's that type of leader that
we like
we just crave like we're just looking up
to someone so smart and bright who can
pronounce all these words correctly
yeah that's really all you can ask for
from my favorite game show host from
your favorite influencers that's why
we're not your favorites
i also feel that way about steve harvey
i feel like he's like someone i can look
up to
yeah and that's what makes a great game
show host i've actually heard that the
weakest link which is now back hosted by
jane lynch is amazing
and that's because jane lynch is a
leader yeah you know mm-hmm
and she's the one i could look up to you
should watch john mullaney's
monologue from snl on monday night
because i think there's something in
there that you're going to appreciate is
it a jane lynch appreciation joke
it's exactly what it is we have no
choice but to respect it exactly what it
is it's as if
he has seen what you have said the
hardest working woman in hollywood no he
definitely pays her the respect that she
deserves
you know there's not enough people who
do that like and maybe it's because not
enough like i had the real
privilege of experiencing a jane lynch
work
gig live she i went to uh
the prime day concert and she was the
host where dua lipa and taylor smith
were performing
and it was live streamed on prime like
worldwide so like hundreds of millions
of people were watching it was like a
really big deal
for her to be hosting it she was running
around the uh
the event space going here doing this
engaging with the audience even when the
cameras were down she was just like so
lovely to people
and that's when i really got the respect
for jane lynch and so maybe not enough
people have seen her in action
live i mean nary a person i know
disrespects jane lynch no i don't think
people think that if they did
out of my life i don't think people
disrespect for i just i don't i don't
think people
vocalize or like appreciate the respect
that they have for her do you know what
i mean
yeah no just like we don't talk about it
just like margot middlebum like
yeah you don't think about it but it's
there right no the people working hard
behind the scenes martindale
what was that margot martindale yeah i
think something about her face is just
like very welcoming like she makes a
lovely biscuit and like
you can cry on her shoulder and she'll
take you in you know those biscuits
delicious i smell them already also one
of
jane lynch's like for me my one of my
favorite rolls that she has
done there are so many obviously sue
sylvester but have you seen
the not another cinderella story with
selena gomez and jane lynch yeah but who
is jane lynch in that movie
stepmother iconic and what
icon she's like the jennifer coolidge
yes
and she kills it wait i'm that's where
drew parker's in it too right
yeah and they're like dancing in the
mirror yeah so much dancing dropped my
ipod
like oh my god did you see that on the
dance floor
oh my god i didn't realize jane lynch i
haven't seen that one in so long i've
seen
not another cinderella wait another
cinderella story with hillary clinton oh
not another
i said that because i just said she's
not another teen movie no another
cinderella story is
hillary duff a cinderella stories
hillary another cinderella story there's
been like four of them guys i've proudly
watched them all
one with selena gomez one with lucy hale
one with um
like greg sulkin and your favorite
person laura morano
oh it was a version of a cinderella
story
and he found her lyrics oh wow wait okay
i didn't know that this was like such an
interest like a franchise no it is
and i didn't know that the movies were
all connected and the lucy hale one is
so good also
oh well i definitely think the first two
should be permanently added to our
content uppers list
don't let the fear of striking out keep
you from playing the game and i'm gonna
say something
so crazy and no one's gonna agree with
me and and
i just i need to just put it out there
like i think the selena gomez version
is just as good as the hillary duff
version no
it's it's really really good for a
sequel but it's never going to be better
than
i didn't say better i said like truly
like if they're both on tv i would
struggle with which one to watch
no i don't think i would it's just i
guess jennifer coolidge
and they're they're tough i don't know
you're not very pretty
and you're not very bright thanks
thanks for letting me know that also
last night i thought of another content
upper that i wanted to add to the list
because i forgot that i watched it over
the summer
and it's such a good movie one because
it has our favorite twins in it and two
it has a real appreciation for camp and
it's it takes two
mary kate and ashley so good so good
watch that last year
over thanksgiving i think treat
treat like such a 90s movie i love that
there's such an emphasis on philanthropy
like it's
such a good emphasis on camp too yes and
such an emphasis on like a big mansion
near a campground with
like what an impact a good counselor can
make it is a psa
for the art of counseling for
counselorship and i think that margot
needs to watch it
because her counseling skills have been
a little have gone down the tubes
and talk about that on this week's
episode of the redheads so those are a
few content uppers that i just wanted to
update the list and i'm glad we spoke
about because
um do we have greatest showman on the
list of course i have to watch it
because bruno's never seen it
and so now i'm and i've been wanting to
watch it anyway i think it's been like a
good year since i've seen it so i'm
ready for like all the razzle dazzle to
hit me again
yeah there's nothing better than like
being so inundated with a movie and then
like taking a break from it
just so you can kind of experience it
all over again yeah
oh that sounds so exciting chills chills
down my spine
um but we have a great show for you guys
today and i think that
if there's nothing else i guess there's
nothing else and if there is you know
we'll mention it all so without further
ado it is time for the fast five stories
that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and i feel like this goes without saying
but today's episode is obviously brought
to you by bruce
which is an absolute favorite here at
the morning toast jackie and i have both
been using our bruce
brushes for maybe like three or four
months
yeah we it's the most fabulous electric
toothbrush that really gets the job done
but it's very reasonably priced
and it comes in super cute colors we
both have like the millennial pink it's
a very toasty pink
um so stunning the brush is really
everything that you need because
brushing is fun
and it's a hundred times as effective as
regular standard brushing your teeth
brush cleans your teeth at 31 000
movements a minute manual brushes top
out at just
300 many electric toothbrushes are
barely a step up for manual ones
and then some of them can do a good job
but they cost over two hundred dollars
bruce delivers premier sonic wave
technology without the markups that big
electric toothbrushes
tack on it's honestly such a different
experience using an electric toothbrush
and i've been
i hadn't used one up until a few months
ago and it's made a huge difference like
in my breath in the color of my teeth
and just the way my teeth feel
and it's really a fabulous product and
if you've been wanting to try an
electric toothbrush but you don't want
to spend
over 200 bruce is the best one out there
and it's very reasonably priced
you can also get 15 off when you uh want
to get a brush when you use a promo code
toast at bruce.com
brush is spelled b-r-u-u-s-h so it's
brushed with an extra you
and you can get 15 off when you use the
promo code toast you can also try it 90
days risk-free and get a two-year
warranty
at bruce.com b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
with the promo code toast the bruce kit
includes the electric toothbrush
three extra brush heads magnetic
charging station which is very fancy
and a sleek travel case so it's perfect
for um
traveling with it it's fabulous it has
six cleaning modes you can use different
like varies
of vibration and it's the daily one the
white one the gentle one the gum one the
max one and the tongue one
and it lasts for up to four weeks on one
battery charge which is amazing but i
always put it back in the battery right
do you do that too yeah sometimes i
don't know sometimes i get a little
crazy i'm like how long can we go
spooky sign on
okay first story britney spears says
she's the happiest she's ever been
in her life in a new instagram video
britney spears wants her fans to know
that she's doing just fine in an
instagram video posted on monday the
singer gives fans
a life update referring to comments on
her social media concerning her
well-being and safety
she said hi so i know that there have
been a lot of comments and a lot of
people saying a lot of different things
about me
but i just want to let you guys know
that i am fine i'm the happiest i've
ever been in my life i'm sending all of
you guys a lot of prayers
wishes and a lot of love now call me
naive but like i kind of believed her
and i know there's all these conspiracy
theories and at the end of the day like
nobody really actually knows what's
going on
in her legal drama in her personal life
her family life nobody really knows
what's going on
and part of me actually like really
believes this especially after reading
jessica simpson's book
where i feel like jessica simpson and
britney spears were in a similar machine
whereas like
they were just told what to do what to
wear what to sing do this for years and
years and years and it really [ __ ]
with their mental health
and then brittany was in vegas and she
was doing shows every night and now i
feel like for the first time in her life
like
brittany's relaxing like and i know it
look like her social media
is like weird to some people that she's
like dancing on the beach and doing yoga
and dancing in her living room and
painting but that's what people like in
retirement do they relax
and part of me like actually believes
that like brittany like might be okay
yeah we did a patreon episode about this
conspiracy a while back during like free
brittany and at the time i was getting
sort of convinced that she needed to be
freed but
uh recently i've just been feeling like
that is not the case and i'm glad that
she put out this video and i hope that
it is sincere and there's no one like
behind her with cue cards telling her
what to say
um because i agree with you i feel like
this is just the season of her life
and i think that she's doing well and it
seems like she has free reign to post on
her social media so she could say
whatever whatever she
wanted and i hope that this is all true
and i'm going to believe that it is like
i think that people got a little carried
away for a second
yeah and maybe that's just us being
naive but like i just i choose to
believe what she's saying in the video
and yes i do know that she's acting a
little bizarre but like
maybe she's a little bizarre maybe she
nobody actually knows who brittany is
like the person behind the woman like
her personality
maybe she's just like a weird girl yeah
like some people just get on social
media and like do weird stuff and it's
like oh that's not the girl i know but
okay but that's who she is it makes you
happy yeah so like if her painting and
dancing in low-rise shorts
is who the real britney is and like
dance girl dance shall stay away
chante you stay yeah i agree i'm glad
that she
put this video out even though i don't
know if it will necessarily equal all of
the rumors and satiate the free britain
you know because with every video she
puts out people are even more
yeah like did you see she was wearing a
yellow shirt and she said yellow in the
comments like
they're like they're insatiable yeah so
but i feel like for people who are just
looking out for the girl you know
not paying it too much mind this is nice
to hear
yeah and i think i think she's okay you
guys
i do i really do good well
a little dancing with the stars news we
haven't spoken about in a while but
there was big news because jenny mai
jeannie mae jeannie mae had to leave the
show no jeannie mai sorry sorry
genie we were both wrong jeannie mai was
told
she had to leave the show she was told
her throat would have closed up if she
had waited one more day
but that's crazy because she was
actually doing a really really good job
yeah she's staying positive as she
recovers from emergency surgery
on sunday she went underwent in
operation after being diagnosed with
epiglottitis so it's is it a
dance-related injury
sounds like it's not because it's her
throat yeah i don't think that it is
it's just crazy a small cartilage lid
that covers your windpipe swells
blocking the flow of air to your lungs
right that's actually so scary yeah so
the diagnosis forced her to withdraw
from dancing with the stars
that's crazy and really sucks because i
think i don't think a lot of people
thought she would make it super far but
she was like really really killing it
and i feel like she was having like the
time of her life so
that sucks yeah that does suck and
i mean this is way more important maybe
they'll give her another chance another
season
maybe i mean i was actually keeping up
with um
social media on dancing with the stars
last night because carriana naba was
like
going hard on caitlyn and i feel like i
saw that she was crying
yeah and last season i um
i had a lot to say about the way carrie
anne was like really going after hannah
and it's like she like always chooses
someone to be really hard on because she
thinks like they're the winner and like
they can do better
and she's like really singles them out
and now i'm thinking maybe she just
hates the bachelor franchise because it
was hannah brown last year i'm like
she's really been going hard on caitlyn
what did she say to caitlin i don't know
just that's what people on twitter were
saying like that's literally where i get
my information
but like always just like pointing out
every mistake like why'd you do that
it's like
because it was a mistake like that's
like it's just really like on it
unnecessarily like specific critique and
even um scores yeah so i feel like maybe
she just doesn't like the bachelor
franchise people were accusing tyrov not
wanting a real housewife maybe
carrion doesn't want the bachelor maybe
that's the cover-up for this real story
maybe maybe she just goes really hard on
the people that she thinks like
are near professional dancers and like
if they're gonna win like they might as
well
she's critiquing them harder than she
would someone who's just like a star
who's dancing right
i don't know part of the reason why i
had to stop watching dancing with the
stars after only watching it for like
two seasons
is because the scoring makes no sense
and it's just like
so the judge like the judging the
scoring and the judges are the worst
part of it
and i just can't watch it then like
disgrace these
the talent you know yeah i understand
that
i feel like the show there's always so
many people that start off how many
people are left like
i don't know i feel like they're
actually getting like it's going by they
are and i i just think that
nelly and caitlin bristol will be the
top two like that's how i feel and i
i by the way i haven't even been
watching but like from when i gathered
on social media and the few episodes
i've watched like that is my
official declaration interesting yeah i
actually really think caitlin could win
what about christelle she's tearing it
up yes she is um
no i just don't see it in my prediction
okay oh she got off last night she got
off last night so i was right i didn't
see her
that's why i saw this story that it was
like her saying that it's been a very
therapeutic process which i actually
think that
it is i just remembered my dream and it
was about christelle which is
so weird and then when i woke up i was
like sofa clamped and ben like literally
rolled over in the bed and he was like i
had a terrible dream and i'm like was
krishnel's house in your dream too he
said
no i had a dream you cheated on me with
a hundred men and i was chasing you down
the stairs i'm like
what kind of [ __ ] do you think i am
like yeah
i thought he was being dramatic because
he was like exact like being dramatic
like a hundred
and then when he got out of the shower
he was still so upset about the dream
and he was like he was like a hundred
men i'm like
so you're saying like one zero zero like
you weren't just being traumatic like
you think that
how can he crowd count so well no it was
honestly so offensive and then he was
like mad at me in the
like in real life for what i did in the
dream and i'm like i'm [ __ ] mad at
you [ __ ] like
100 dudes that yeah like what do you
think of me how big do you think my
vagina is like chill the [ __ ] out
wow i had a dream the other night about
gary from rascal flatts
wow he was doing a solo concert and he
moved my seat i was in the nosebleeds
and he moved me up to the front row
and then he brought me on stage wow well
you know
people's dreams are like a real insight
like window into their subconscious
and your subconscious is just like truly
delusional
that's honestly like the craziest dream
i've ever heard in my life why i feel
like it could happen
i could manifest it you could i mean
gary is i follow him on tick tock he is
releasing
solo christian music yeah no and like he
was thinking like just rascal flats bops
and i like was singing along every word
and i was so enthusiastic that he pulled
me on stage honestly like that's
something that could happen to me
yeah well can i say something actually
um
back to christian music really quickly
so there was a lot of people when we
were talking about yesterday how like we
can't have christmas trees
a lot of people there's a lot of
confusion who celebrate christmas are
like
what that's crazy like i have a
christmas tree because it's a holiday
tree like it's a winter thing
it's not like a christ jesus nativity
thing and people are going back and
forth about whether or not jewish people
can have
um christmas trees and they were varying
opinions and obviously everyone has
their own interpretation of the holiday
season
but a lot of people did really call you
out for being obsessed with christian
music and
wearing merch that says jesus is king
and then not letting me have a christmas
tree
yeah no and i and it's a it's a conflict
that i'm constantly in conflict with
because i'm so like
pumped about christmas holiday season
hallmark like i really love it all
especially
like the the festivity of it all and
i feel like even everyone can agree a
lot of these holidays have become like a
hallmark holiday you know
more like american yeah instead of
religious
specifically and i try to you know keep
that in mind and
i really do love christian music and i
love the message and yes sometimes they
thought of jesus and i'm like
jesus take the wings oh yeah but
i mean but i can still enjoy it and i
just i like i think it's
extremely uplifting i actually do feel
and i
kind of strange when i wear the jesus
king sweatshirt
i mean i would too because i was in the
airport once i was wearing it
and i was going through security and the
person behind me was an orthodox jew
and we're both jewish and i'm here like
jesus
he like has to go through life like
bearing the bur
the visible burden of being jewish and
like but we're both equally jewish
and like so true i really felt like a
fraud and i haven't worn it since
wow yeah no i by the way i never thought
of that that's a really really good
point
yeah so but the thing about the tree is
like there's nothing i mean some people
make it more of a
christian religious symbol than it is
other people plenty of non-christian
people
have trees i just think that is where we
have personally
always drawn the line like we always
have loved the showmanship of christmas
and the holidays
but to get a tree for us just takes it
to a place of like
being unfaithful to where we come from
right and that's just
a line that we've drawn i'm not saying
it's like that for everyone but
no but also we've always said that so to
just one like that is
for one season to be like you know what
i'm just gonna get a tree this year like
it's just the way that we yeah i don't
know
it's just it's honestly it's devastating
it gets harder every year
to not get a tree i agree but i think
that and i was looking up some inspo
like from
like people who have like hanukkah trees
and they get like light blue ones and
they have like
jewish ornaments and it's like literally
the cutest thing ever and it's just it's
really hard
i'm sure it's very very cute and i'm
sure it would be really nice but
you know just think of like
no i can't i mean you you could do what
you want i think everyone can do what
they want just for me and you
you all know how much i love the
holidays and how much i would love a
christmas treat
like so badly for bruno to lay under oh
could you imagine
honestly now that i think about it like
with all the pines falling off you would
just be eating them it would actually
probably be a nightmare
you'd have to get one of the fake ones
like one of the ones from shark tank
yeah and to be honest
i would 100 get a fake one like
regardless
like with the water it's just too hard
with the real one yeah
well i'll just be sitting here without a
tree we did a patreon episode about our
judaism a while back
and we had a really in-depth
conversation about this like the
christmas tree
thing in particular so if you want to
hear like more of our thoughts
in depth and not just like this
explanation
head over to patreon.com morning toast
and by the way our thoughts
don't speak for anyone but ourselves so
like if you're jewish and you want to do
it like do whatever you want and you
know what
if you want to do it do whatever you
want no no i can't because i feel like i
would be ashamed i'm not my sister's
keeper
no i think you are actually no no no i'm
not no i relinquish
my no it's okay it's fine i it's fine
okay it's totally fine next up and fun
i mean like you don't even like since
when it's just like i
since literally spending nine months in
my house and just like wanting a tree
why don't you get a plant so much work
get a palm tree
with the watering yeah then like the
dirt theo would jump
in get all dirty i just know it so
that's a tree johnny depp loses his
london libel case involving
ex amber herd so even though amber heard
allegedly took a [ __ ] in the bed
even though court docs reveal this was i
haven't been keeping up with this story
except for that anecdote of the duty in
the bed
and the court came to the conclusion
that it was most likely a pet
not a person who took a [ __ ] in johnny
depp's bed and i don't know if i'm gonna
agree with the courts
on that um that's up to you but despite
the fact that there was a [ __ ] in the
bed
johnny depp has lost his sensational
libel case against the british newspaper
with a judge concluding that the
hollywood superstar star regularly beat
ex-wife ever heard after an explosive
trial that included allegations of
everything from adultery
to defecation in the paris marital bed
i'm glad it resonated with this article
as much as it did with you
it's an important part of the case
london high court judge andrew nickel
delivered his decision following three
months of deliberation
the claimant has not succeeded in his
action of libel
um he said that the newspaper that the
sun had shown that it's 2018 story
under a headline calling dep a wife
beater was substantially
true wow that's crazy that like
so if you're suing for libel you have to
prove that what they said isn't true and
therefore the court
proved that he did abuse his wife which
is really horrible
really horrible that's crazy and why
would you sue something like
wouldn't you sue you when you super
liable like you sue
when you really really know you can win
like very few celebrities ever sue
because
as a public figure you're open your life
isn't open to interpretation
very rebel wilson won
a few years ago in australia and they
ended up appealing and i think she had
to give back her money
katie holmes won once i think against
star magazine and it was like the
biggest deal ever
it doesn't ever really happen and if you
do take it all the way to court it's
because the law is on your side so i'm
very surprised that johnny depp
would take this all the way to the high
court in london
even though he didn't really have a case
yeah and along the way we've reported
some of the instances from these stories
and it was a very
messy troubling [ __ ] filled yeah
literally so i just feel like amber
heard like
needs inner peace yeah you know i think
everyone in the world needs inner peace
yeah no it's a very stressful time i
think that we could all really benefit
from just
from like not [ __ ] in the bed
watching the sunset
gaining inner peace you know what here
is claudia ashrae's guide to inner peace
oh my god i'm [ __ ] swimming in my
eyes he's crying that's how beautiful it
is
no i got some [ __ ] in my eye i think
amber took a dump
um but this is i feel like this week
everyone's really going to need to find
their inner peace and however it is that
you do that
i just want to give some of my
recommendations for inner peace if you
live in the mountains or like near the
beach
your key to inner peace is right around
the corner i feel like i'm really
talking to people who like
live in apartments you're talking to
claudia and jackie ashrae
yeah and um here's some key standard
piece i would really find a hobby i took
up coloring
and it's really been very peaceful i
also have my knitting supplies sometimes
it's nice to just like
not be inundated with media and not like
scroll your phone like let people miss
you like let a text message go
unanswered for 20 minutes
it's really really peaceful a glass of
wine didn't hurt if you smoke pot
that helps like anything just like calm
your senses a bathtub some bath salts
watching jeopardy anything relaxing that
really can just
take your mind off of things temporarily
you know
that's nice a bathtub with some bath
salts maybe half a zan
don't eat the bath salts yeah and don't
like take drugs and take a bath
oh definitely don't do that yeah yeah
take that back yeah i take it back i
rescind what i said
do one or the other um and if you're
prescribed
of course and i think that's beautiful
claudia maybe try a book
light a candle yeah light a candle yeah
take a nap with your puppy that's the
cutest littlest thing that you've ever
seen
you know what actually really helps
contribute to inner peace if you have
the lighting in your house on a dimmer
i i do my whole house is on dimmers and
i just never use it they're either like
on or off
and i feel like dimmed lighting is a
really under
appreciated like home aesthetic yeah i
don't have dimmers in my house but i
never turn the lights on in my house
like anytime someone comes over they're
like do you have lights i'm like oh yeah
i guess i do
your lights are never on they're never
on i just like i find them to be
overbearing i feel like i'm under
investigation
instead we have like some led lights up
and we have some lamps that are like
touch on we have some candles
and we just are always creating a mood i
really never have my over like overhead
lights on
i have them i'm like 24 7. are you okay
you're feeling emotional
no literally there is like something
stuck in my eye and i just
why you were closing your eyes when you
were talking about inner peace yeah i
was trying to get the thing out i
thought you were trying to like
bring yourself to a place of interest no
i was just trying to get the thing out
of my eye and it's still here
oh great okay but don't worry about me
carry on with the show sister
carry on carry on with the show brother
forever where's grandmother
khloe kardashian denies she's pregnant
and she reveals her
couple's halloween costume with tristan
and true they dressed up as cleopatra
and mark antony and someone commented
something about her being pregnant
and she quickly retorted saying
that um well mostly that she's not she
said
someone said chloe's going to tell us in
a couple months that she's pregnant on
twitter chloe was quick
to shoot down the speculation saying
well my abs say otherwise
i mean honestly this confirms that
they're
back together and i don't know why this
is like the most toxic relationship that
i just like stands for so every time i
choose a story about them i'm like
girding my loins because i just know how
you feel about them but i
really did choose the story because you
were the one who like were saying like
she's responding to you
yeah no i didn't say she was pregnant i
think that you did
i said kylie's pregnant and you also
felt like she was too i said she could
be
right but i didn't i didn't like put my
stake in the ground there i put it in
the ground with kylie
you did um i just thought this was
information you might want to know yeah
no and something about
them um i don't know it's like not
really bothering me
right now i agree because you see like
also offset and cardi b
um took their divorce away like they're
not doing it anymore
um and people were like so mad about it
like i actually like really stand that
toxic relationship as well
so there are some toxic relationships in
hollywood like i have time for and some
that i don't and currently
i have time for cardi b and i have time
for chloe it might change
i don't know but right now i'm okay with
it yeah because it's like we're all in
quarantine there's nothing to do like
if you're not hooking up with your ex
like what are you doing yeah
there's no one else how you ever gonna
meet someone new you can't go to a bar
yeah so you just gotta [ __ ] tristan and
i understand their halloween costumes
were really cute
oh and then at the end of the day both
of them have both cardi b and both
clothes
chamber have babies with their toxic
exes
so i just want like i want the families
to be happy so sorry i'm just like such
a family-oriented person
no i mean that's who you are oh my god
my [ __ ] eye
what's in there like honestly amber
hurts duty like i've never been more
sure
it hurts um i'm just going to talk like
this for the rest of the show yeah just
or just like cover your eye with you
no this is me um embracing johnny depp
aye aye oh my god totally you were
inspired by the story
um so yeah i'm happy for chloe i think
the costume looked good it did lack a
little bit of originality like gladiator
okay cool been there done that um but
it's okay because i'm happy for her
know that she is are you ready for our
fifth and final story
a little interesting statistics news oh
you know i love me some statistics
there is a new most viewed youtube video
ever that has beat despacito by louise
fonzie featuring daddy yankee
and i'm going to give you three guesses
as to what it is okay
it is the newest most viewed youtube
video ever
i got it can i do a dance move sure okay
are we on the main camera we're on the
main camera i think i know it
oh wow dynamite
yes no oh [ __ ] it should be
[Music]
okay
if you're watching on youtube you could
say um okay so it's not is it something
from this year
um no no
2016.
what does the fox say no wow
okay
no the most viewed youtubers like
international
like sensations you're you're on the
right track okay wait
is it k-pop uh technically
sort of i'm like but i don't think that
helps you
okay i don't know just tell me it is the
morning toast halloween episode
no it is baby shark oh i never would
have guessed it south carolina shark is
k-pop south korean children's song baby
shark dance becomes the most viewed
youtube video ever with 7.04 billion
views you know they are really onto
something in the music industry in south
korea like they're just lighting it up
dynamite like dynamite yeah that was
something that i wanted to watch
blackpink light up the sky
their documentary on netflix looks so
good yeah
love it love it they have a song with
cardi b that's about to be released as a
single that is
so [ __ ] good i think it's called
minky wanna and their new album is
so good yeah and as much as i've tried
to avoid the selena gomez song it's all
over tank talking like it's actually
really good no it is really good yeah
that the whole black pink album is
really good there's one other song on
the album i've actually been meaning to
discuss this because i've been loving
like
listening and writing to them the other
song is you never know it's a bit of a
slower one but it'll balance
it'll get you i mean i'm just so caught
up with bts and like i'm in love with
one of the members the one who's like
tall and dyed his hair green for a
little bit
um i just think he's like so handsome
and i love him
and um yeah i'm really excited for like
their next single to drop
you because dynamite for me personally
i'm just going to go ahead and say it is
my song of the year
oh i i give the green light popcrave had
a tweet that was like of all the
number ones this year like which one is
your number one of the number ones
and for me it's dynamite you know it
really is like the song
of the season and it really i think the
marker of a good song is like
really the way that it makes you feel
and in these current times like i've
been listening to so much music
mostly depressing music and something
about the song dynamite like really puts
me in good
spirits and i think that that is in this
year in particular like a really
important
element of a good song yeah and when i
see that samsung commercial and i'm just
like
i'm gonna buy samsung like it's so
influential so excited when i know that
commercial
no i completely agree like every
commercial should use that in the
background and then i won't mind
watching commercials
see and i've only recently been turned
on to bts and it's not because i wasn't
listening to them like
i think when they had that song with
halsey like i thought it was bad like
yeah i i just feel like now they're
making music more like for for me
and i also like savage love savage love
that's jason darullo and bts it is
uh-huh
oh my god why are we singing
ever since we downloaded the app have
you been spending a lot of time i've
been trying not to and
you know what's interesting yeah now
that i have puppy
i'm on my phone a lot more and i'm
holding my phone like kind of away from
him and my carpal tunnel
is really bad and even it was happening
also when i was trying to read on my
kindle the way i had to hold it so he
wouldn't grab it like
even redoing the position now like my
wrist hurts no i feel that i really do
i feel like kanye he said on joe rogan
that he was texting too much
and um he had like hand problems
yeah me too i got tendinitis in my right
thumb is very painful
yeah so like that's when you know
actually i haven't ever i have been on
my phone more
ever since i got puppy my screen time
was up nine percent which we
hate to see why does the puppy correlate
with more screen time i guess because
i'm just sort of like sitting with him
on my phone like
i don't know it's just something to do
while i'm just petting him
well those were the fastest stories and
i feel as though you needed to know them
i really did feel as though it's
extremely important that you knew that
baby shark is now the number one video
on youtube i
always think that that sort of thing is
interesting because it's not what's big
in america youtube is a global platform
and more often than not
the biggest videos are foreign yeah no
and
it's like the kids you know it's always
the kids the kids are going ham for baby
shark
big time which we knew but like now it's
like the kids have superseded the adults
that song is just like living in a
palace baby
all right now let's go to tv recap
because i really want to talk about the
american murder and the tv recap segment
is brought to you by stamps.com
this holiday season more people will be
mailing stuff than ever before and that
means the post office is going to be
busy you don't have time for that
stamps.com brings the post office and
now ups shipping right to your computer
mail and ship anything from the
convenience of your home or office
with stamps.com anything you can do at
the post office you can do with just a
few clicks
plus stamps.com saves you money with
deep discounts that you can't even get
at the post office
stamps.com brings services of the us
postal service and ups right to your
computer
it is a must-have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
out invoices
an online seller fulfilling orders
during this record setting holiday
season
or even a giant warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day stamps.com
can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official u.s postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pickup or drop it off it's that simple
and with stamps.com you get five cents
off of every first class stamp
and up to 40 off priority mail and up to
62 percent off ups shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer it saves you
time and money so it's no wonder why
over nine hundred thousand small
businesses
already use stamps.com don't spend a
minute of your holiday season at the
post office this year
sign up for stamps.com instead there is
no risk and with our promo code toast
you get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts required just go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in toast
that's stamps.com enter
codetoaststamps.com
never go to the post office again now
that's a promise i can
i can get that's a beautiful promise
yeah okay so the american murder first i
just want to talk about like the actual
programming an hour and a half
thank you so much i hate documentaries
that are just like especially ones that
are like painful stories that are just
dragged out i thought this was very
concise and i agree with you the footage
was
unbelievable the fact that they didn't
have anyone like sitting down and
talking to a camera is crazy it was all
police
body camera detective room
investigator room footage and the ring
doorbells and her facebook
and her stuff which literally between
photos and videos we saw
all the whole life yeah um there were a
few really key moments for me
i thought it was really really
interesting how the day
that like shenan went missing and that
police guy showed up to
the i forget their last name home
uh shenan's house they went to the
neighborhood they went to the neighbor's
house and that neighbor was like
he is not acting right yeah he knew that
second that's crazy yeah i also felt
like the documentary really
highlighted the emphasis of like being a
good neighbor and being a good friend
and a good like a part of your community
because it's like
they knew this to like some people just
don't answer their phone for a few hours
but
so many people around here like knew
immediately that something wasn't right
and all the people in the neighborhood
like
were canvassing and i just feel like it
was like police work and like
neighborhood
watch work like at its finest and it was
just like good citizens like doing the
right thing
yeah no it was remarkable that her
friend who had dropped her off like knew
she had just
appointment at nine o'clock and she
didn't show up for that and then she
wasn't answering her phone and by noon
like she really knew something was wrong
and i feel like
that might have not been it might have
taken longer had
they been different people yeah and
obviously the craziest part about this
story is the fact that
chris the murderer husband was
involved in the police investigation
like making videos for the news like
being a true [ __ ] sociopath
and obviously we learned that he is the
one who murdered his kids and his wife
and at no point did he ever give me like
serial killer vibes like
it was crazy and if he had not gotten
caught like he would have gone on to be
like one of the biggest serial killers
of all time because
first of all he really showed like very
little remorse and he still lied about
killing his kids and tried to blame it
on their mom
right and what you eventually find out
where
there was that hour car ride where
shenan is dead in the car and the kids
are riding out to the oil tank with him
and it's like
he had all of that time
to and decided to kill his daughters
and when he said where they were buried
like my
jaw absolutely hit the floor like the
the thought process behind giving your
wife a proper burial and then throwing
the body of your children
in an oil tank like what why don't you
just bury them all
i was so i couldn't believe by that that
just rocked me i don't understand why he
didn't bury the girls i mean i don't
understand a lot of things that he did
but to me that just like
was beyond the pale
it's just vile horrific and
and i didn't even think about it but
when the when shanann's dad was talking
at the end of the documentary that he
really believes in his heart that like
he killed
shanann while she was sleeping because
she didn't fight back and he had like no
defense
wounds on his body like no scratches no
nothing and she was face down
i didn't even think about that but like
100 100
yeah yeah it was a really crazy
it was a really well done documentary
yeah a horrible story
a disgusting man just like i am just
thrilled that he like literally is
probably like having the worst life
right now like
i just i love that for him yeah also i
was telling you
because i tried to do like a little bit
more research but pretty much the
documentary had everything but
this is crazy i read in the daily mail
that he had gone on like tinder dates
and
and had had other affairs and one woman
who he had gone out with
um she recounted a lot of disturbing
things about him but she also said that
together they watched the movie shutter
island
and in that movie leonardo dicaprio
kills his wife because she drowned their
kid
and that this woman believes that that's
where he got the idea to say
he killed his wife because she killed
their kids right that was like the most
important i mean
it was all [ __ ] terrible but like to
not only do what you did but then to
like
have shenan's name be like dragged
through the mud and imply will not imply
accuse her of killing the kids like to
me that
was just added a whole other level of
like
depravity and inhumanity to this already
[ __ ] up situation
yeah and her family was just like they
were just like regular people like
the whole thing was just like so regular
you know what i mean like someone
assuming they lived in this nice house
in a cul-de-sac
drive to pick up truck it was just like
a very average life and
it's just it was very disturbing
so disturbing like and he i guess his
motive was because he wanted to like be
with his
friend and have a new life like just
like the prosecutor said like get a
divorce
no no people do it all the time all the
time 50 of couples they say actually
just do it and they move on just fine
and then the statistics at the end of
the documentary were also really
chilling like three women a day are
killed by their
partner or ex-partner which is an insane
statistic
more often than not is men and it's more
often than not premeditated
crazy oh and the added layer of facebook
groups
the most toxic places right that's what
i was trying to tell you like just when
you thought like
shenanigans is the victim here of course
like no matter how you slice it and the
fact that people in facebook groups were
like finding a way to
disparage her character was just based
on her mothering tactics this like
disgusting cherry on top
to to be honest like i really wanted the
documentary to give me the names and
addresses of people who said that like
it's it's such a disgusting thing to say
like you deserve to be
in prison for saying something like i
know we live in a free country but like
it's so disgusting like i mean yeah
that's the opposite of freedom of speech
but like you should be
like it's so vile and knowing that
those types of comments were getting
back to her family yeah [ __ ]
toxic facebook groups like it's insane
and she just like i don't know she was
just like such a cutie like with her
kids and her
obsession with videotaping everything
like in live streaming on facebook like
when she was like text me when you're
coming down the escalator so i can film
it stop i'm actually gonna cry
like it's too much like it's really too
much um
honestly like i hate this man so much
like i wanna go visit him in prison and
stab him
like i just wanna get involved because
i'm so upset like oh my god
and the girls the girls i can't oh and
pregnant made a name for the baby nico
yeah it's just i can't
a [ __ ] honestly it was really
triggering like if you
don't handle things like this well i
honestly wouldn't recommend watching it
it's just such a disturbing story
and then seeing it all play out it's not
dramatized it's not movie this is the
real [ __ ] people
yeah when the body cam footage when
chris ran up to the house like for the
first time we're meeting chris i'm like
that's the murderer like he's very
[ __ ] there get him
yeah it's just crazy and honestly i feel
like the where was the colorado police
department like it was very good police
work at first i was like
why are they rubbing his shoulder like
this guy's a murderer like we're really
like coddling him but it's obviously
like a technique to make him feel like
he can tell them anything and then just
like tell him what exactly what he did
but it was it was good police work it
was good everyone did
their part yeah like his girlfriend
nicole she didn't hold back she went
no one she recognized that she was being
lied to
she she told her story which was a major
piece to the puzzle
yeah so everyone just did the right
thing but it's just a
horrible story but a very well done
documentary i will say and
i have many critiques about many
documentaries but this one was pretty
good yes
um so that's what we watch i still
haven't watched the holiday i'm
definitely going to watch that
and what else did we talk about um
cinderella stories sagas maybe i'll
watch that today too
i wonder where i can find one i just i
don't know something about watching the
hillary duff version like
she's kind of annoying in that movie
sorry i said it sorry i said it
really yeah just like she's like with
her
phone i actually like her in general but
i just think that in that movie she's so
annoying
waiting for you is like waiting for rain
in this drought like i can't no but she
gets empowered at the end and i i live
for her no
she actually ruins the movie and that is
why
it's like bumped down to being as decent
as the sequel but chad michael murray is
just like
so everything and i love him
yeah there was a time in my life when
like i really really dead ass thought
like i was gonna marry him
we should do a week where we watch one
like a cinderella story
every single day i'm not really
interested in seeing the newer ones i
can't i think you need to see the one
with laura morano
why i just think that you meet i saw it
and so i think that you do as well
i mean i live for a greg sulkin moment
yeah i'm just like i'm
i haven't really kept up with the work
of laura morano since um
ally and ross no and also she was in
that movie
what's that show called ally and aj no
that's what i was thinking too
austin and ally thank you same thing no
but also she was in a movie recently
that yes yes it was netflix
you were not a fan it was awful
just truly abhorrent a disgrace to the
filmmaking
field okay maybe we won't do that then
well that's our show everyone reminder
it is tuesday make sure to get out and
vote
get your voices heard take care of
yourselves because election anxiety is
real
um and we'll see you back here tomorrow
hope you have a great day thank you so
much for watching the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart video catbox
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast and
leave a five star review about how
beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing day and we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day
goodbye
[Music]
you